ho trovato un fucile a corda raga
Benvenuti ragazzi al secondo episodio di
Sons of the forest Let's go best scelta
ever
Patrizio Cavaliere allora allora allora
è morto sei morto mi sa che è morto Ah
mi ha dato e leirtag localizzatori GPS
servono Ah ce lo spazzolino prendi
sempre tantissimo
cazzo è Oh mamma mia ragazzi non ho
capito neanche se ho dei Core Madonna di
Dio eh fratello devi prendere le pagaie
e pagaia No state lontani da Giovanni
come torno in spiaggia c'è uno squalo di
merda
testardo e non si fanno niente Non è una
roba normale ragazzi Guarda che cazzo di
pennuto è un robot Oh minchia un'ora e
mezza non è proprio il posto ideale per
fare questa cosa Però almeno no fratello
no fratello non hai capito Ci provo e
non ho altro modo se non fare questo e
sperare che non mi mangi vivo
attenzione raga
ce la fa Ce l'ho fatta non so come non
mi ha preso Madonna son stanco morto Uh
le tartarughe questa sarebbe Ragazzi
allora mi dispiace tantissimo fare sta
cosa mi dispiace
eh però servono raga serve perché il
guscio serve per raccogliere l'acqua è
troppo utile non posso non prenderlo Eh
lo so che lo so ragazzi lo so mi odiate
lo so e tu che minchia sei devo Madonna
quanta roba guarda la bottiglia Prendila
prendi una [__] bottiglia che ti
porti l'acqua dietro Mamma mia devo
insegnare tutto Cos'è questo bevanda
energetica con l'ex C'è roba Ci sono
padelle cose Prendi tutto
corda per teleferica per quanta roba sto
trovando Ragazzi ma che è non comprendo
come una radio possa prendere eh fino
qua Però vabbè Queste sono questi sono
dettagli che non andremo a scoprire
Kelvin Tesoro se ancora qua che fai Non
ha fatto un cazzo no Invece va fatto ha
fatto invece guarda lì bravo
Oh minchia è utile quell'uomo facciamo
un Raw pesce così almeno mi recupero un
po' di energie perché sono un po' a
secco e dopodiché ragazzi Io andrei
visto che abbiamo la pistola possiamo
provare provare ad andare nelle caverne
Vediamo che succede ragazzi eh Bravo
guarda che uomo guarda che muscoli
Madonna come mi piace questo Mamma mia
quanto ti pagano non è abbastanza
bravissimo Minchia non devo fare niente
Questo gioco fa tutto lui la caverna sta
là eh raga Allora io intanto mi mangerei
sto rovesci Appena è pronto sei pronto
già ora pesce che recuperiamo un po' di
energie se tutti li lasciate al agli
alberi recuperi forza han cambiato
proprio il modo di di abbattere gli
alberi
adesso C'ha proprio la sua fisica di
caduta prima che aveva un po' cazzo
ma belli bellissimo amica ma se mi ci
metto anche io in due la finiamo subito
sta roba Eh Madonna ma era Iper ragazzi
hanno fatto i per realistico cioè
pazzesca sta roba cioè per tirare giù un
albero porca [__]
io mi ricorderò per sempre la scena
mitica con Decarli sempre me la
ricorderò mi senti tu dal gioco Aspetta
aspetta mi senti la gioco perché ci
aveva Acceso questa Guarda Premi qui Ah
ah ah
ah
Oddio Guarda dietro Guarda dietro ti ha
scassato tutto No no Allora ragazzi
siamo avanzati un po' di rifugio un bel
po' direi vado a fare le cose che
servono queste sta roba qua binario per
pistola
ho trovato una pistola potenziata adesso
non ho capito come ho fatto Ci metto un
po' ad andare nella caverna Eh ragazzi
però è necessario perché le caverne di
the forest sono il posto migliore per
capire cosa sta succedendo
sostanzialmente che le caverne si
svelano segreti perché gli indigeni
nascondono tutto là dentro e c'è un
sistema nell'isola di the forest c'è un
sistema di caverne che è più grosso
nell'isola stessa un sistema di caverne
interno e là dentro è pieno zeppo di
segreti e misteri ed è importante per
noi andarla perché troviamo un sacco di
roba io ragazzi ho la pistola e nel
momento Esatto in cui sparerò per la
prima volta perché il si gegnacci non mi
hanno detto se c'ho i proiettili o meno
non te lo dicono però se io sparo spreco
colpi Quindi l'unico modo sarà a sparare
a qualcuno Ecco è quella di prima non è
quella di prima è un'altra ragazzi
Attenzione
attenzione siamo arrivati ragazzi alla
eh alla caverna Proviamo a vedere cosa
c'è all'interno ricordiamo
non promette benissimo Però vediamo
Eccola Salve Allora io
[Musica]
non vedo niente Innanzitutto questa cosa
fa luce che merda negozio di orologi va
bene però vediamo Ah eccolo qua Ah Non
lo posso prendere Però perché sei
stupido perché potresti portartelo in
giro ma no andiamo pure con l'accendino
che cazzo fai
Ma è scemo Mi sono mangiato un essere
umano
Questo è scemo questo Ah ma non è un
essere umano è roba per terra mangiamo
pure roba trovata per terra non vedo
perché no non ho idea Ragazzi di cosa ci
possa essere qua dentro Eh non lo so
sicuramente indigenit quello poco mi
assicuro ma è per forza rosa è sto
accendino qua ragazzi Vedo qualcosa
laggiù ma non ho capito che sono
indigeni o no per ora pipistrelli per
ora pipistrelli tutto normale c'è
un'altra luce
ci sono delle luci che
C'è un tizio
spara la pistola spara è un buon segno
Porca [__] adesso capite Perché non
gioca Wordon
headshot è morto
uno steccato Uno l'ho seccato non ho i
non so quanti gol ma sono infiniti
proiettili della pistola
Ma porca [__]
è morta Ragazzi ma quanti colpi ho nella
pistola Scusate
è veramente
Porca [__]
No non è infinita Porca vacca ho finito
i proiettili
ce l'ho fatta è morto sono morti tutti
però non ho più proiettili della pistola
eh C'è un tizio impalato
c'è Ah non è impalate su una scala Ma
che cacchio state facendo qua Ragazzi
comunque vi ricordo Nel caso lo fosse
dimenticati che la trama ma questo lo
posso rompere no ok che la trama di Sons
of the forest Siamo noi che dovevamo
recuperare un miliardario la sua
famiglia a scomparsi teoricamente no qua
stavano cercando l'isola Ok si vede qua
stavano cercando ma da sotto mi fa
vedere la mappa del No non mi puoi dare
niente perché vabbè ho trovato Uh
cartucce
Crocifisso Ecco questo Croce collected
va bene posso equipaggiare la croce tipo
cazzate
Ma che cazzo ti dice il cervello Vabbè
non ho idea No no non so se sta roba
posso servire vediamo
Tu madre Io vado avanti e più c'è roba
strana Comunque ho una croce non ho
paura di usarla Croce
Peccato perché secondo me poteva
funzionare Posso avvicinarmi a suo zio
perché c'è qualcosa potrebbe essere
proiettili per favore ma quello di
Resident Evil quella della parte della
casa cioè sto Blob bruttissimo
sono sono bomba temporizzata
ti devo dire aspetta bomba a
temporizzata
ragazzi
è un mio amico quello
sicuramente più utile della Croce questo
Mi dispiace Mi scusi Porca [__] che è
successo eh
raugambaro braccio
e vabbè vediamo se riesco a vedere se
c'è qualcos'altro Buongiorno buongiorno
che Ragazzi faccio un sacco di gente
posso passare inosservato perché vedo
che non so se funziona sta tecnica
ragazzi Però vedo che sono nascosto
potrei provare
passare
so eh
mamma mia ma che schifo è cosa succede
fratello fuori dalla discoteca
dov'è che è andato Ci sono i bimbi di
zoo di Curie Sì vabbè vabbè
non so bene se questi possono allarmarsi
Dubito se ci passo piano di fronte
perfetto Let's go Adesso ho superato
tutto ma non vedo niente se non
accendono non so dove stanno perfetto
Ok teoricamente una buona parte
l'abbiamo fatta eh
molto rumori
una buona parte l'abbiamo fatta non so
dove stiamo andando a finire
non so se è giusta che entrassi così
tanto Però vabbè Tu vedi che ogni tanto
Vedo delle luci Se non fosse per questo
non saprei C'è un tizio che via via via
che sta vomitando quello lì perfetto
Ah ah ah
via via via via via via via via via via
via via Salve Arrivederci
sei male mi ha fatto malissimo Salve eh
Non fate caso a me che sto correndo
Spero di riuscire Madonna ragazzi No
vabbè sono morto sono morto
stanno seguendo questo non ci fosse un
domani sono morto non sono morto
Accendi non vedo niente
C'è qualcosa da ridere
Santo Dio
dove cazzo sto andando ragazzi devo
curare mi ha tirato una di quelle botte
Minchia che male se se in alto dovrei
uscire prima o poi no Porcaccia vacca no
raga Cioè non non riuscirò mai più
Oh Oh
cos'è sta roba cos'è
che cazzo stai facendo la corda fucile
corda con l'ected
perfetto
ricarica premendo Ma che cazzo vuol dire
posso arrampicarmi
mi fanno male Ahia Porco demonio e
mandatene a [__] tutti Sto morendo ho
trovato un fucile a corda ragazzi
aiuto e là sparati
Yes l'hai preso è morto non l'ho
arpionato lo sta tirando verso di me
lo sta tirando Okay Ahia che cazzo era
Ahia
che male
dove vado cosa succede lo capisco
Io andrei giù però
è pazzo
Beh è andata meglio del previsto Vabbè
sono vivo ma non ho più medicine ragazzi
sono praticamente schiattato
praticamente cioè contro qualcuno sono
morto a meno che non
la pistola è proprio si chiama Mannaggia
Ah no
c'ho ancora colpi di pistola Minchia sto
qua fa dove li ho trovati
Oh Santa della Madonna via
Ti prego una piccola Minchia ragazzi
c'ho troppa roba Non posso morire ci ho
trovato di tutto da arpione o [__] che
cazzo come ho fatto a sta roba
ti prego no no non è uscita non è
riuscita forse è l'uscita
Dimmi che l'uscita
[Musica]
è uscita ce l'ho fatta Che culo Dove
sono Dove sono Dove sono cos'è Kelvin
qua
Kelvin Ma che cazzo fai qua Questo
tronco sei stupido devi andare a casa
non mi devi seguire Sei un idiota Però
vabbè Mamma mia sono contentissimo di
vederti Non hai idea
Seguimi Ma che cazzo fai qua Madonna
incredibile segui quei Buglio Ma sei
scemo Mamma mia ragazzi c'ho tutto sono
vivo È un miracolo di Dio ma che via via
Kennedy via Di qua Via andiamo a casa
che c'ho talmente tanta roba che faccio
fatica a capire che cosa ho trovato
quindi devo andare lì e riorganizzare le
idee fighissimo però giorno eh Non
voglio farvi fuori tipo Bambi cioè sto
cercando di prendere cose qua Oddio sa
Guarda non sono mai stato così contento
di vedere casa guarda Mamma mia che
ansia devi vivere vuoi fammi dormire per
favore voglio voglio solo dormire Mamma
mia ragazzi che gioco Guarda quanta roba
allora ho trovato pesci cibo in scatola
pallettoni eh
arpion fucile a core Ma che è
parola che ho trovato allora adesso c'ho
i proiettili quindi forse è veramente
sono infiniti non lo non capisco orologi
da fare invidia anche a surry un altro
po' eh eh Croci soldi teli corde ho
trovato un botto di roba ragazzi Meno
male tu che tu hai smesso di fare la
casa quando me ne sono andato cioè
proprio non una cosa doveva fare Vabbè e
quindi ragazzi Anche il secondo episodio
di Sons of the forest è finito Spero che
vi sia piaciuto Ci sono ancora un sacco
di cose da scoprire iscrivetevi al
canale lasciate un mi piace e Commentate
qua sotto su cosa ne pensate perché
ormai ci siamo addentrando un po' nel
gioco Aspettatemi anche i consigli
effettivamente Magari sapete cose E noi
come al solito ci vediamo al prossimo
video bella ragazzi